his homework mystery show it's it's the
morning show mysteries and this
installment is a mortal mishaps starring
the fabulous Holly Robinson Peete has
Billy blessings and the detective who is
trying to figure out whether she's
innocent or guilty is the fabulous ripp
Rick Fox and I hear that you actually
have a cameo I was told that tonight I
do have a cameo I'm not going to tell
you what the Cameo is oh yeah I'm an
actor
executive producer of this and so I
guess in a way I'm kind of pulling an
Alfred Hitchcock you know making a
little appearance in my own film we're
very excited to see it I also have to
ask you how's it been having Jota take
over the anchor seat it's you know it's
it's one of those things where it's just
completely natural I mean Oda's been
there and everybody loves Jota so it's
it's it's it's been seamless yeah we
were with willie Geist actually a couple
days ago and he said that he's spoken to
Matt Lauer have you spoken with him and
we have and you know we we wish nothing
but the best for for him and his family
and they get the the support and the
help that they need with all the
allegations that have come out in
Hollywood how do we move the
conversation forward I don't know I I
think people have to treat people kindly
in the way they want to be treated
themselves I mean I think it still all
boils down to the Golden Rule business
there was some reports out there that
Matt had actually been still somewhat
involved like texting you guys notes
there any truth to that I don't know I
doubt that I mean you know it's it's I
think a lot of times what you read is
what's happening